we're actually deviating from our
schedule you were going to be hearing
from Tim more he was gonna give an
amazing talk on in depth of how to use
systrace but before you hear that you're
in hear from me who's going to give him
not a much less exciting and technical
talk about new Android features is
important for games or at least that's
what it says in the schedule that's
actually going to be covered by this
talk but you know the truth is what I
realized is as I was coming up with this
talk that that most of you are not all
that interested in new Android features
because basically you're in targeting
90% of the devices out there and you
know the new Android features are gonna
be on on a fairly small amount of them
so you know what I really should do is
come back to you in like a year and be
like okay here are the new Android
features and as soon as I can actually
find my mouse pointer on one of these
screens there it's there it's there
they're there that's incredible
somewhere it thinks this monitor is
Hardy alright there we are ok good as
where I thought it was all right so
instead instead of instead of actually
talking about this one I'm actually to
talk about is migrating your establish
game to target Android oh and Beyond and
why is this actually relevant to you
well I don't know how many people you
actually saw this but back about six
months ago we announced that all apps
and games on Google Play will have to
target the latest SDK version of about a
year ago in order to in order to be able
to continue updating on Play and in all
new titles have to actually target SDK
26 or higher as of August if they want
to be on play at all and you'll notice
if you upload something today you'll
actually get a warning that looks like
this that says exactly what I put here
so you don't have to read it so the real
question is like what does this actually
mean okay first of all let's let's go
over the real basics of what SDK
versions are the min SDK version is the
lowest version your your your office
willing to support and usually tie this
into you know this grid of
the latest devices platform
distributions like the compile SDK is
literally the headers and libraries that
the app that the app links against and
the target SDK version is this really
important one and this is the platform's
way of ensuring backwards compatibility
and this is this really says to the
world I have tested my game on this
platform release and and and what
happens is the system only applies
certain kinds of behavior changes to
target these specific SDK versions and
so technically your compile SDK needs to
be at least as great as your target SDK
and min SDK but usually obviously you're
actually thinking about wanting to
target a very large swath of the use of
ecosystems so you're actually going to
make the compiled SDK equal to the
target SDK version which is going to be
much greater than the minimum SDK
version all right that was probably
confusing but and at a time it impacts a
whole bunch of things if you haven't
gone beyond let's say M you have to deal
with changes in runtime permissions
alarmmanager
manifest declared broadcast receivers
and background services and your mic you
might be saying okay well look I'm using
one of these I don't care about this
stuff at all okay I mean they're just
gonna handle all that for me right I
mean how is this relevant I'm talking
about Android API to a bunch of game
developers and well first of all there's
a possibility that you might have
something else beyond that in your app
and and these things might not be
compatible with the latest version of
Android and so you have to look at all
of these plugins and what they do and
how they're impacting things and of
course it's very possible we also have
to update the version of the platform
for one of those two big things which
can be a lot of work so let's talk a
little about runtime permissions if if
you're still targeting L which hopefully
most of you aren't this is something
you'll have to deal with and this this
is actually really good I think I think
runtime version is one of the best
things we ever did because it allows you
to ask for sensitive permissions in
context and not on permissions or
runtime ones just this like really
simple and easy to remember list but the
good news is that is that that's not the
way the user sees it
we actually users actually see it like
this
so calendar phone camera sensors
contacts I mean none of you guys ever
need any of this stuff right and of
course you know just because your game
isn't yet turning em admittedly this is
you know not a game but it's an example
of something that doesn't yet target him
the user can still go on these devices
and they can show all that stuff off so
so it's still good to actually
understand how this works because and
you might be thinking all right well
this is easy what I'm gonna do is just
prompt all of these things right up
front right my game starts I'll have
like you know five permissions that I'm
going to go ask for and this is a really
good way to make someone never run your
game again okay why does it want to have
access to my contacts right now that
makes no sense that's really scary go
away so it's if it only needs the camera
permission when it's actually doing some
cool stuff with AR mode then ask for the
camera permission then okay it's it's
it's really really important it I know
is there some work involved here but
it's so it's so important when someone's
getting the first impression of your
game the first thing you see is like I
want to know all about you and
everything you do so another thing that
is going to change is alarms and alarms
are actually my favorite api's because
it's just hilarious now they take two
different forms they have literal arms
and we have schedulers for background
work and and and this was originally
really how you did background work on
Android in early versions of a you would
schedule an alarm and you would wake up
your app in the future and we decided
was that was a bad thing because a lot
of apps are all waking up at the same
time or even waking up at various times
and it wasn't allowing us to prioritize
system resource as well so back in
KitKat we decided okay we're not gonna
make we're gonna make it to the alarms
by default are not exact unless they're
explicitly requested and this is all
stuff that only happens if your target
SDK version changes so so when we added
this thing called well set means that it
will happen around the time that you
said it would happen and then we have
set exact which means it's really gonna
happen at that time that you really said
it what's going to happen this is how
this how API is evolved and the thing is
that this is actually code from the
support library so if you're using this
port library and have to care about this
you call set exact on older versions of
call set on newer versions it costs that
exact and it works the same way
now the alarmmanager then we had more
changes and we went to doze which which
hadn't happened in android m along with
ron time permissions and and we realized
oh well now we've got this problem that
the device could be asleep and and we're
only allowing apps to run during these
maintenance windows during that time so
he added we said well said exact isn't
good enough because that exact stat
losing in a fire during these
maintenance windows and we now added set
exact and allow while idle just to be
really explicit we like long function
names it's very self documenting and
these actually can wake the device from
doze and again here's what here's what
the compatibility story looks like here
and once again there we are and it
actually just calls into the previous
function we just showed you if you're on
older versions so very very very very
simple and and yes this allows you to
fire in the middle of doze might not
want to do this cuz it's pretty bad for
battery life but it does give you a way
of doing it so after all of this if
you're going to be running a bunch of
work in the background probably don't
use alarms at all actually consider
using like something like you know well
actually yeah probably probably the fire
base job dispatcher at this point
although we've got some news coming
tomorrow so stay tuned so broadcast
receivers also changed and you know
these have used been used by the
platform to notify apps response to
system-wide events and what a lot of
apps used to do was they used to hang
around and you say oh I want to wait for
Wi-Fi so I can download a whole bunch of
stuff in the background and that's and
not and not actually impact you know the
the data of the user all that much which
is good because user sudden they say app
using tons of data they'll uninstall it
so we have like 10 apps all fire at once
as soon as the as soon as the device got
on Wi-Fi like you plug it you plug the
device in the device would heat up and
you know it's a really bad user
experience honestly and it whatever
they're doing in the foreground gets
could get the completely trash so we
decided this is a bad thing so we said
alright you know this is one of these
things that gave developers great power
and with great power
you know it comes great responsibility
and it responds the way these endpoints
were used we took all the power way so
you can't actually launch the app any
more in network changes happen however
we did actually
at least once you target Oh now the good
news is first of all some of these act
some of these broadcasts other than
network actually still work because
there's simply no other way to do it so
like if locale changes well a bunch of
people like really there's a broadcaster
in the locale changes that's cool but
yes and when locale changes you can even
or accessories are attached a lot of
these things are just the kind of things
doesn't happen very often
buuut completed you can still use so if
you need to like have alarms or the
things you have to register during that
that still works but for the most part
most these don't work anymore
so if we're network broadcast however
you can use job scheduler firebase job
dispatcher or some other things and that
allows you to actually say hey I want to
make sure that my job gets run when I
actually have Network this is cool you
can be downloading new stuff from the
background this is what hopefully all of
your SDKs you're using that are doing
things like ads they're not using this
if they're not gonna work really well
I'm going going when you go and target
Android oh and this is cool you can
actually set all sorts of information
about the network type for example here
so you can actually say hey I want to
only have this running when I actually
have Network which is cool so you can it
can actually let you know that there is
a network available and more importantly
it can also say I only want to run an
unneutered networks which is which is
kind of a cool thing so you can say hey
and you can even do cool stuff like like
I want to run an unneutered networks but
I want to have a watchdog that hangs
around and says if it hasn't run it if
my job hasn't run within 24 hours let's
run it anyway it's that kind of thing so
you have a lot of you have a lot of
options here and and and if you do have
to use something for backwards
compatibility for an old version Android
like have some connectivity changed
thing you can one of things that's
really cool is you could actually leave
it disabled by default which is which is
cool I even know you could do this in
earlier versions of Android I'm like oh
that's awesome but it's been always
there and you can actually then turn it
back on so you can say okay well now I'm
on this ancient version of Android let's
turn this back on that'll allow me to
still be launched on an old version and
still use the old api's another thing
that people want to know about is when
their package gets uninstalled and
reinstalled with the new version that's
actually kind of a useful thing and a
lot of them would go and say let's look
to see all of the packages on the system
and and when there
and when that happens and that's really
bad a lot of a lot of apps were actually
doing that and so you can no longer do
that but you can actually used my
package replace to find out when your
own specific plac package gets replaced
which is good there's also actually an
API if you do want to find out when
other packages are been replaced on a
regular basis you can actually pull for
them with a sequence number so you can
say oh has anything happens to last time
I run so if you're if you want to if you
have other apps or either of their
you're trying to check to see that are
companions or to the one you have or
just want to check to see how many how
that's going on in the system you can
still do that without actually having to
have your app wake up every time another
app is installed it's much better okay
so let's talk about background limits as
well this is also something that has
that has changed with Android oh
probably the biggest change is it lets
so is it when you're in the background
you can't do a whole bunch of things
like you can't launch services anymore
and this is a big change for a lot of
these SDKs it's just kind of a suit oh I
could always do this
and so what does it really mean to be in
the foreground well it means your app
it's visible means that as a foreground
service foreground service is that
service that actually has an has a
notification of sociated with it all the
time so the user knows it's always
running sometimes they'd be kind of
annoying they show up in as this thing
that's running and you're in your
notification list but it's really
important that it's visible to the user
it's your app is essentially in the
foreground at that point or if it's
bound to an app that's in the foreground
it also it also if you're doing one of
these things which I don't think any
game developers are using except maybe a
wallpaper service you're also in the
foreground you're in the background when
you're not visible and when you're not
running a foreground service and if
you're running one of these job things
or broadcastreceiver
so and if you're running on o plus
starting a service in the background
throws in the legal Sadek section if
you're targeting out so this is a pretty
big deal it's actually tank affected
some of my code and this really changed
the way Android dealt with running stuff
in the background in a really good way
for users and a way that makes things
slightly more challenging for developers
so you can you can if you can still
start services that are running in the
background when your game is in the
foreground and and those will continue
to run for about a minute after your
game is exited and it doesn't mean that
your code stops running remember Android
these are these
our hints to the OS for how to schedule
things more than anything else so it
doesn't mean that your app immediately
gets closed after it gets back rounded
that your code stops what it does mean
however on Android o is that you'll
actually lose your way clocks and this
happens for everyone so even so once
your app no longer has a running service
on Android o your wake blocks will be
automatically be cut off if you don't
have you don't have an activity or a
service or ik or a broadcast receiver or
a content provider running your way
clocks get cut off and that's actually a
good thing we had a lot of apps that
were just hanging around all the time
and keeping wakelocks open and wasting a
lot of battery and so this is actually
something that affects you on o
regardless of whether or not you're
actually targeting o but on earlier
versions you can keep the service
running all the time and on oh you can't
and there's still a few cases where you
can actually run and you still watch
background services so you can actually
do this when your app is responding to a
notification that and the system even
still and still thinks if your app is
being foregrounded so that's kind of
good high priority firebase cloud
message also is considered being in the
foreground and that also wakes you up
from doze so don't use it very often
less you have to like really important
timely things and SMS and MMS delivery
which hopefully no one here is going to
be that provider and then we also have
behavior changes and you know you might
not notice these yet depending on how
many of your users are actually running
Oreo but we have a lot of limits on
background location so which are good
this actually is important a lot of
actors hanging around all the time like
where our users and so you can't do that
anymore you can you get much less even
if you request tons and tons of location
updates if your app is running in the
background it just does not have a
foreground service then you only get a
couple of results an hour by comparison
it's actually a lot more than that but
it's a lot less than it was even Wi-Fi
scans are actually are actually cached
so if you keep scanning Wi-Fi over and
over in the background it's only going
to give you a couple a few updates every
hour by comparison to what I was doing
before so you use things like geofencing
for example if you need to know when the
user reaches a specific location you can
do things like you only have a hundred
of those you can use things like dynamic
geofencing with regions
these are all really cool things you
want to do cool stuff with your game if
you want to have like hardware beacons
in places or that's pretty cool too
that's another way using the nearby
api's there's a lot of ways to get
around that use batching if you if you
want to attract people's location
hopefully a lot of games aren't doing
this but you know location-based games
are getting more popular all the time so
you can just check check this max wait
time here and that will allow you to
batch up location updates for you and
then you can also use passive locations
this fastest interval here actually will
mean that okay yes I'm not requesting
getting updated all the time with
location but if someone else is using
Google Maps or there were Reno or using
you know acting activity tracking and
somehow for sports or something like
that that I still get those updates to
so it's kind of a cool way of doing that
so another thing I want to mention is
that Android keeps introducing battery
optimizations that are based on
deferring restricting background tasks
so again we talked a little bit about
doze this this this limits app activity
to maintenance windows when things is
like our unplug or stationary that kind
of thing and and then we actually added
those on the go it's not really calling
it it's doze light but it's it's for
when it's for when it get it still
limits things to limits most things to
maintenance windows when the device is
unplugged in the screen is off like from
the users in the pocket it does allow
for a few things that aren't allowed
during during regular doze and then and
then we also did this thing called app
standby so if someone doesn't use an app
very often it starts slowly limiting
what the app can do and that's really
good because a lot of like I install
apps that I only use when I'm in certain
places and this allows me to to make
sure that they're not constantly
draining my battery but for a game
developer it does mean that if someone's
not using your app all the time and
you're trying to do all sorts of stuff
in the background you'll stop they'll
stop seeing these things and then stay
tuned we have a lot more stuff coming in
P that we'll be talking about tomorrow
so how do you test these things it's
pretty straightforward you can test
those this way using an ADB command you
can see how and this allows you to see
how your how your app actually performs
when it's running in doze mode you can
test app standby by doing this you have
to unplug the battery but you can do
that with this nice command that makes
it makes the system thinks the battery
is unplug
before you start doing that okay and I
did mention I was going to talk about
kind of modern things you could take
advantage of you know one of things you
have to take advantage of his
notification channels because if you
don't have notification channels and
you're targeting oh your notifications
don't appear they just don't show up so
you you really want to turn this on and
this is actually really cool because if
you actually if you actually give the
user good channels and explain like this
is a really high priority notification
and these are things you might be
interested in these categories it
prevents them from actually disabling
all notifications to your game and
that's and so this is actually something
I definitely recommend really thinking
about and and and trying to trying to
make a user scenario with like okay well
actually you know what I really do want
to know when there's a cool free offer
here but I don't want to be notified
every single time that one of my friends
comes on that sort of thing and so you
can you can you can really make the user
make good choices that say you know what
I don't want to disable all the
notifications for your app because they
at mean something to me but I can
actually use these channels so Recker i
recommend really thinking about this it
actually has helped us to we've actually
seen in devices that have notification
channels we actually see less people
turning off all notifications so it does
actually work one of things you also
have to think about is if your app is
using immersive mode or you know some
games actually do use this translucent
status bar which is kind of cool I wish
more did you have to think about this
display cut out because a lot of apps
and games assume that the the status bar
was like 28 pixels tall 28 divided
density-independent pixels tall and
turns out it's not true if you had these
cutouts and you can also stimulate a cut
out using the P Developer Preview image
so that's useful probably not a lot of
things make sure probably the biggest
thing for game developers actually that
that some games aren't still doing is
dealing well with long aspect ratio
screens so this has gotten a lot better
recently I can't imagine why but I guess
I guess long aspect ratio screens are
getting important are getting more
common but they're still games that will
occasionally have content that's cut off
because a lot of a lot of people really
think of things in terms of things the
layout of their of their HUD in terms of
of having a fairly limited set of aspect
ratio so this is something that's
definitely worth testing for and these
are going to be
you know even more common this year you
can letterbox things if you want another
thing I haven't seen any games doing but
I'm sort of waiting for it is actually
supporting picture-in-picture yeah
obviously people use it for chat but I'm
sort of waiting for something especially
I mean honestly I want Pokemon go to do
this because it'd be kind of awesome to
have like my little Pokemon character
running around in the corner while I'm
doing other things so I put it there
also we do have volcn think of taking
advantage of it these are the new
changes we that are in Vulcan 1.1 which
is actually part of Android pee which
we're finally implementing multi-view
which I'm really excited about for VR we
also have the memory models and are
necessary to have much better
compatibility with hlsl shaders which is
cool of people who are sharing those as
well as some cool things for video
processing and for open CLC
compatibility so again there's there's a
lot of cool stuff there to consider
using Vulcan another thing that I really
really like and this isn't part of pedis
was actually and added in Android Oh is
a audio which is our new audio API it's
really straightforward to use like
really simple by comparison to using
opensl and the best part about it is we
actually have this library called oboe
that wraps hey audio and wraps opensl
gives turns and uses one API with a
audio you also can get access to
something called sharing mode exclusive
which actually gives you super super
super low latency so it's really for
like hardcore rhythm games it gets you
down to you know sub ten millisecond
output on on devices that support it at
least our devices and it's pretty cool I
definitely recommend taking a look at
oboe here's a project you can go to oh
yeah yeah there's one more thing that we
did in an android p that i wanted to
make sure that you knew about and that
is that we actually got rid of the
ability to call most private api's now
if you've been watched following us we
actually in the NDK we stopped people
from calling most private api's in
android oh and android p we actually saw
stop people from calling most of the job
the api's that are running in the kind
of native sort of java level and there's
a Wii there there actually are quite a
few that are still
aloud we're in the process of trying to
meet go through the SDK make sure there
were all the things that are really
useful are actually and relevant and not
scary are turned into into proper api's
and and so that we're trying really hard
not to actually hurt people's
functionality with this but what I want
everyone to do is test your game on the
Developer Preview too because if your
game doesn't work on that it might be
because one of these API is is no longer
allowed and it could be one of the one
of the libraries that you're bundling
and one of the plugins you're bundling
one of the SDKs you're bundling along
with it that's causing it so I highly
highly recommend testing on DP two with
DP one we would throw up a toast when
these things happen with DP two it'll
get logged in logcat and the apple crash
and what will happen in the release
version is probably something in between
so I'm not guaranteeing not just because
something crashes in DP two doesn't mean
it's going to crash so if you have a
problem with it and you're saying hey
this middleware doesn't work report it
to us file an issue and we might not
actually make that crash in the final
version but if no one files these issues
it's likely to go out as it is so this
is just something you should know please
please please please PLEASE test against
it review - it'll be coming out very
shortly you can also use this strict
mode VM policy to actually detect
whether your app has doing any non SDK
usage so this is great even if you don't
have the source code for a bunch of the
plugins you can you can run this this
will work on Android P Preview - and
this will allow you to actually see ok
does my game actually do this even
though I don't really realize it is we
also have this site we've put up on the
on DAC to help you transfer transform
your app or game to the new target SDK
rules it's a it's a pretty good thing
it's a pretty good thing to check out
we've spent some time on it so hopefully
most of the information I shared here is
is review for you hopefully most of your
art already targeting relatively recent
SDK versions but if you haven't just
this should hopefully help and and and
that's it for me so I hope this was
informative and thank you very much
and I can I've got a couple minutes for
questions yeah if we get the mic over
yes one thing to add for the target SDK
version is also the 64-bit in 2019 yes
so I'm actually gonna have yeah so so in
20 so this is another really important
thing when I have my colleague Dan who's
gonna come later who's from the NDK team
is gonna talk about this instead this
year it's targeting it's targeting P
nets hurting Oh next year it'll be
targeting P and tarting you every app
that has a native component will have to
have a 64-bit binary shipped alongside
any other binaries you want to ship so
you could if you want to just ship
64-bit you can do that
but it's something that's been needed to
happen a lot of in the future is 64-bit
and then the other question I had was
about notification channels are we going
to see a way to actually prompt those
categories within the actual
notification system os within the app
itself as opposed to directing users to
settings to customize those that's a
good question I don't I don't think so
not yet but I know that they are that
that they're gonna talk a little bit
about notifications how they're
revamping this on the notification
channel stuff tomorrow so I definitely
recommend watching the a little bit I'm
on that in the what's new in Android
talk anything else yes I can repeat the
question too
which which lately oh sorry actually
we're gonna read this one got recorded
too so so well we shall have that we'll
have that up later soon hopefully so but
also I'm giving a version of this talk
which is slightly less focused on game
developers at i/o on Thursday
so there'll be a live stream to that and
that will actually probably get even
faster than this one
if they will have it'll have a few other
it'll have a bunch of corny jokes and
and it will have a few other things that
I can't talk about now so it might be
worth you checking out as well the i/o
presentation